we just ran the pipeline for RNA seek as
I said it's gonna take a while for it to
run and so if yours later we go to check
we go to my pipelines and we see the
ones that we I just helped upon are
still running but here we have one that
I have previously run another day that
is finished click on lesson 2.3 we go to
job output files and and we said we
wanted a filtered zeros and here we have
expression tables for genes and isoforms
and I'm gonna click the download special
tape of genes isoforms and then we can
go to excel again screen and we import a
text file
it is tabbed eliminated text so we're
going to go dilemonade it just tab and
put it in your sheet or existing sheet
and here we have in our rows are all of
our samples and our columns are genes in
the ensemble format name we're going to
go to find and right here we have the
ensemble name for crafts which is a
proto-oncogene and we can find it right
here and we get the expression data and
we see it's pretty much zero for
everyone except pretty low expression
here one for the sample and that's how a
when you look at the data and in future
videos we're going to show you how to
actually analyze the data using machine
learning using a t-test and how they
make sense of the data